hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it competitive especially in today's
case will take two A-list filmographies
and see which one looks better in a tux
or at the poker table and especially
saving the world that is when you know
they're not um recharging in the bedroom
oh everybody needs a hobby I'm your host
Mark Ellis and I'm not sure James Bond
ever got eight hours of sleep but he has
been played in recent years by two
critically acclaimed and audience
approved actors that have delighted fans
around the globe with their
distinguished takes on 007. it's not a
compliment it's a ballyhood bond brawl
featuring Pierce Brosnan and Daniel
Craig right now on versus of course
Pierce and Daniel won't be here in
studio they're way too busy with
upcoming projects outside of MI6 and
while Jimmy Bond will Factor heavily
into how this match plays out this is a
contest that accounts for the sum total
of Brosnan and Craig's career highlights
in one corner we have Pierce Brosnan
what no small up no Chit Chat who after
missing out on playing bond in the mid
80s took up the mantle in 1995 with
GoldenEye before it became a video game
and we're going to make three more Super
Spy Adventures into the New Millennium
in the other corner it's Daniel Craig
who may not have looked the classic Bond
part when he was cast in 2006's Casino
Royale but we all quickly forgot about
that and would enjoy four more 007
outings all the way up through 2021's no
time to Die the final bondian effort for
Craig both embodied the legendary
character and made him their own now
it's time for the sky to fall for one as
the world is not enough for both here's
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score round three iconic rolls
round four powder and then we'll do a
Wild Card round that could involve Bond
villains double 07 romances or stuff
that M has no clue about like
investigating homicides run by fruitings
or the ultimate sin Bad karaoke your
host this guy goes way back with both
top talents so I first discovered Craig
in a cool flick called layer cake then
he goes and books a roll of James Bond S
I know that and even before Brosnan
appear to Mrs Doubtfire I remember him
from the Stephen King VR Thriller the
lawnmower man remember that movie
Stephen King didn't like it he actually
sued to have his name removed from the
title but the future man it looked cool
in the early 90s James Bond now he's
always ahead of the technological curve
and his flicks go all the way back in
time to the early 1960s as a matter of
fact last season right here on versus we
did a bond batch to determine who really
is the best of the punch was it Connery
Craig Brosnan you gotta watch that
episode I can't give away classified
British intelligence
I wouldn't do anything
but it came down to the wire as I
imagine this battle will as well look
Ethan Hunt is great Johnny English is a
legendary name in my household but
there's no substitute for Bond James
Bond martinis are on the way the poker
cards are dealt let's get it on I'll get
on with it then
nothing can be as painful as listening
to you talk round one box office I'd
forgive those of you who might have
assumed that Pierce and Danny I
shouldn't call him I am the future
so don't you ever talk to me that way
again yeah Pierce and Daniel didn't make
a dent in the box office until they were
on the posters for GoldenEye and Casino
Royale respectively but like so many
villains hell-bent on world domination
you'd be wrong for Brosnan a start on
stage thanks to none other than
Tennessee Williams in person proved that
he could act then a successful run on
the TV hit Remington Steele showed that
he could carry a franchise maybe a
little too well you see he was a
front-runner for the role of 007 for the
movie The Living Daylights but couldn't
make it work with the TV schedule so
instead Bond was rebooted with Timothy
Dalton at the helm but in the early
1990s Brosnan had a modest hit with the
lawnmower man and it's how much it only
made 32 million dollars worldwide man
everyone in my class was talking about
it it had job the future everything it
doesn't work like that and then juva
deny a Doubtfire came along in late 1993
and who wooed its way to a 441 million
dollar take which is still good for
second all time on Pierce's theater
going receipts list number one well duh
it's got to be a Bond movie right what
is it golden eye or The World is Not
Enough Tamar Never Dies Die Another Day
nope it's the other Bond movie Mamma Mia
maybe he's been down here too long which
I'm now being told is not in fact 007
Canon it came out in 2008 alongside
fellow cinematic Legends like The Dark
Knight and Space Chimps and Mamma Mia
would go on to make 598 million dollars
people love Abba especially when those
songs are his wonderfully sung as Pierce
does this one Rises to me the challenge
ah beauty is in the ear of the beholder
wow
you know where you stand Brosnan did do
quite well with his spyrific run gold
and I re-established the character for
Generations new and old earning 356
million dollars globally Tomorrow Never
Dies almost matched its Big Brother with
339 million dollars The World is Not
Enough Jess eat past the golden one with
361 million and Die Another Day
Brosnan's final Bond outing in 2002
raked in 431 million dollars in
negotiable bearer bonds the preferred
currency of action movie Bad Guys
everywhere
money
then there's this Daniel Craig lad to
many he was an unknown quantity when he
landed the gig for Casino Royale but the
reality is he'd been a part of some
hugely successful cinematic undertakings
already can I interest anyone in Lara
Croft Tomb Raider starring Angelina Joey
and Danny Craig I suppose you she's a
greedy unscrupulous sellout and do just
about anything for money it made 273
million dollars back in 2001 when Pierce
was still Bond and the very next year
Craig played a loose cannon type and
wrote a Perdition alongside Tom Hanks
and Paul Newman that movie would end up
grossing 183 million dollars but unlike
Brosnan Daniel Craig's box office resume
does feature 007 at the very top his
five best movies in terms of movie goers
buying tickets are all Bond Adventures
Skyfall did over a billion bucks worth
of business the only Bond movie ever to
achieve such a feat Specter took an 879
million dollars no time to die amassed
760 mil after over a year sitting on a
pandemic mandated shelf Casino Royale
kicked us off with a sterling 594
million dollars and Quantum of Solace
brings up the rear with 591 million
dollars so Craig appears to have the
dollars and sense advantage over Brosnan
in terms of spy Adventures but how about
outside the world of Q and his
incredible gadgets does it do anything
it tells the time remember brosden has
Mamma Mia and Mrs Doubtfire can Craig
match let's go to the world of Animation
The Adventures of 1010 earn 373 million
dollars and we don't talk about that
movie Enough The Golden Compass brought
in 367 million dollars and we talk about
that movie an appropriate amount
that is hooey The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo did 239 million dollars Cowboys
and Aliens another 176 million bucks but
the difference in this round might come
down to another character of Daniels
that seems to be heading towards a
full-on franchise enter
block a new Knives Out Adventure hits
Netflix this year the first one cut up
over 300 million dollars in theaters
okay so Pierce is on the ropes here but
he's still got some swings left you have
Percy Jackson in the Olympic torch
whatever that movie's called burned over
200 million dollars worldwide and
Dante's Peak The Foreigner The Thomas
Crown Affair and Mars Attacks all
surpassed the 100 million dollar Mark
which also seems to be James Bond's
travel budget whenever he goes on a
mission think about it the dude travels
first class custom suits many expensive
drinks lavish dinners with fine ladies
gambling away uranized life savings you
know rescuing the world really ain't
cheap
toast your evaluation shall we when it
all comes down to it Pierce Brosnan
films total 4.3 billion and that's not
factoring in his newest Blockbuster
Black Adam meanwhile the other DC Daniel
Craig his career Cinema earnings succeed
6.3 billion dollars his per film average
is 243 million PBS is a hundred and 11
million so Craig has the numbers
advantage in round one and if you're a
Brosnan fan screaming at your streaming
device an activity I like to call script
teaming remember this Craig does have an
uncredited cameo in Star Wars the Force
awakens and I recall that movie doing
okay how much
two billion dollars not that we were
going to see Stormtrooper number nine
but it's a fun fact another one is that
Daniel Craig wins this round and goes up
one to nothing you have no idea who
you're dealing with round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score and now we
head to the newspapers Holland the
presses
this Justin in addition to telling you
what movies were playing where when
they'd also have reviews of said films
usually on a Thursday or Friday from Top
critics there's no news
like bad news it was a very simple and
convenient way to start your day but now
of course we have the ease of online
news information people yelling at each
other there's a whole generation out
there that has no clue how to tidally
fold a newspaper and leave it in the
bathroom but today's Tech also has
blessed us with the Tomato Meter a handy
guide for how a wide swath of pro-film
pundits felt about a flick and the
audience score an aggregate of how
Regular Joe Schmo moviegoers were
leaning after seeing a movie and while
bond is a Top Line credit for both Bros
and Craig it might come down to their
other work that decides the Victor in
this round Daniel Craig gets off to a
hot start in the Tomato patch with a
slew of hits that are at least 90
percent including 2007 Tales casino
royale's at 94 percent Skyfall is 92.
you can also brag about Logan Lucky's 92
percent or his all-time top score which
is 97 for knives out sounds about right
that's also the high Mark for Brosnan
but that was for a film in the early 80s
called The Long Good Friday what the
hell is that well in addition to being
one of Brosnan's first ever roles it
also starred Bob Hoskins and Helen
Mirren all right I'm listening excuse me
Dame Helen Mirren but Pierce would never
recapture the magic of The Long Good
Friday in which he played first Irishman
at least in terms of Tomato Meter score
but he does have the Ghost Rider at 84
percent golden eyes at 80 percent and
the second Mamma Mia is at 79 percent
the first one I'm glad you asked because
uh oh no oh boy it's rotten at 55 I'll
now pause 10 seconds while many of you
regain Consciousness and as a reminder
my podcast Rotten Tomatoes is wrong is
here to help we defend rotten movies we
love like Mamma Mia or it's theater
companion in the summer of 2008 Space
Chimps which is unfairly maligned at 33
percent and while Brosnan has plenty
more freshness in his bag of tricks like
Tommy Crown in his affair at 70 and the
Matador at 74 percent GoldenEye is his
only fresh outing as Bond numbers were
never my strong suit Die Another Day and
Tomorrow Never Dies are tied at 56 and
The World is Not Enough is the low bar
at 51 despite starring Denise Richards
as a rocket scientist named Dr Christmas
Jones
007 you're incorrigible always wanted to
have Christmas in Turkey
Craig was more consistently fresh with
his bond outings including Quantum of
Solace at 64 percent Specter at 63
percent and no time to die at 83 percent
the dude went out on top Munich is at 78
and The Girl with the Dragon Tattoos at
86 percent it seems like Craig is
inching towards another battle one here
in round two so let's go to the law of
averages Daniel is fresh that is with
the audience 65 is his average over
there thanks to Knives Out in Casino
Royale staying in the 90s but his Tomato
Meter average is just rotten at 59 maybe
Glass Onion gets him into good spelling
territory so now the door is open for
Pierce Brosnan who's competitive on the
audience score metric with a 52 percent
average thanks to GoldenEye and both
Mamma Mia films being fresh here plus
you guessed it The Long Good Friday on
the audience score 89 we all got to
watch this movie it's a crowd pleaser
critical darling big stars it's got it
all but is that enough to get broads
into fresh with his Tomato Meter average
to to quote Judge Judy yeah
48 is his average there and
unfortunately I think I know why so in
addition to his James Bond films getting
sillier around his class the lawnmower
man is also rotten at just 37 what I
guess you're not ready for that yet but
your kids are gonna love it wait the
audience scores 31 I don't understand
people anymore take me to space with the
rest of the chimps Daniel Craig wins
another round and suddenly has a two to
nothing lead I know this seems terrible
but let's not be too rash round three
iconic rolls well we know the name
that's going to kick off this face right
we're on agreement Pierce Brosnan and
Daniel Craig could go on in their
careers to play fictional icons like the
Easter Bunny or Freddy Krueger or real
life people like Leonardo da Vinci or
Santa Claus but they're always going to
be most remembered for playing the
coolest buy of them all boom
James Bond Brosnan rescued the franchise
and it was on the ropes and when his run
of movies started to get a little too
silly Daniel Craig ushered in a Brawn
ear more Rough Around the Edges bond
that was needed for that time
James Bond so if they were both just as
one character we'd have a tie on her
hand but round three it's about the
entirety of one's career and all these
characters that these professional
thespians have inhabited and they're
going to check into the ball game
let's play ball first up possibly a new
franchise star Benoit Blanc Mr Blanc if
you please a mix of Colonel Sanders and
Foghorn the Leghorn you're a pack of
vultures at the feast Knives Out beaks
bloody courtesy of Daniel Craig and
knives out Craig has also donned a fun
accent for Quality films like Logan
lucky but in the knives out series he's
the detective whose unusual methods make
for an enthralling suspenseful and very
funny mystery solving romp a case with a
hole in the middle
a donut what an achievement to play a
role that is equal parts scene stealing
funny man and movie anchoring lead with
such a plump I have a feeling that Glass
Onion will not be the last time we
welcome Benoit into our living quarters
but if Bond was the ultimate role for
both actors what better training than as
a thief turned private investigator in
the popular 80s Show Remington Steele
Brosnan's character might have been on
the opposite side of the law the Jimmy
bond is but Pierce demonstrated a
Panache a smoothness and a suit wearing
confidence that felt so positively
double 07 even the pilot episode was
dubbed licensed to steal but on the big
screen it wasn't until Mrs Doubtfire
that brazid would be a memorable face
and one scene in particular sealed the
deal it was a run by fruiting he's the
new bow on the Block and old pal of
Sally Fields and her ex-husband Robin
Williams is having none of it but I can
also sing his Praises as Dr Lawrence
Angelo and the lawnmower man since
apparently none of you will 31 from you
the audience and I trusted you job
trusted you so Jeff Fahey plays the lawn
care guy who's low on the IQ chart but
keen on following Angelo's experiments
within the realm of virtual reality and
psychoactive drugs that improve his
cognitive abilities drastically I was
born dumb Pooh hits the fan and the
story does bear such little resemblance
to Stephen King's original tale that
King successfully sued to have his name
removed from the film's title but the
end scene oh the phones start ringing
it's good stuff definitely at least 50
percent Worthy on the Tomato Meter Craig
can be wonderful when starring roles
like layer cake and Defiance but he can
also hit home runs with smaller parts
like the quick to violence Conor and
Road to Perdition or as Steve in Munich
but Brosnan's range seems to be a bit
wider as he can go from villainous like
in the Foreigner to mysterious as with
the Tower of Panama to just outright
Goofy with Mamma Mia my sentiments
exactly of course when these fellas get
in their action wheelhouse like in The
Thomas Crown Affair or Cowboys and
Aliens they're pretty tough to beat
so Brazen gets the edge here simply
because he's had more time in his career
pre and postponed to ingratiate us to
Creations that would run the gamut at
your local Blockbuster Video
I mean the guy helped us avert two
disasters kinda in back-to-back years
with 1996's Mars Attacks this could be a
cultural misunderstanding and then
1997's Dante's Peak that's enough for me
to award Pierce's first victory of the
afternoon and now he's on the board it's
two to one lucky my eyes
I can beat this man
round four powder yes sometimes I have a
very good time naming these rounds
something vague or mysterious or even
dangerous you know like a scintillating
Bond adventure and so this phase is
called powder because we're going to
decipher who is the best 007 between
Craig and Brosnan the Gold Bond if you
will keeps you dry fresh and shaken not
stirred before I run through each
iteration of James Bond and why it's
wonderful I'll remind you that both of
these dudes were more than just another
good super spy they were essential and
came along at the exact time the
franchise needed them the most I'm a guy
who's easy to please too Connery might
be the best Roger Moore was great in his
era and George Lazenby could actually
fight but I'm also a fan of Timothy
Dalton's work in the role although by
the time Licensed to Kill was released
in 1989 it felt like James Bond and all
of his wonderful toys signatures and
charm had run its course so the property
did what seems to be harder to do these
days it took a vacation a long one it
went to go get its groove back and when
it returned in the mid 90s the goal was
to go as classic as possible while
simultaneously updating the characters
and feel for a new decade thus whoever's
going to be stepping into the tux had to
have a Timeless quality that could
Captivate multiple generations with
their personality enter Pierce Brosnan
he was perfect and at just the right
time and possibly handsome endlessly
charming and with just the right notes
of sensitivity and toughness a standard
operating procedure Brosnan revitalized
James Bond at a time when action movies
were increasingly about the biggest guy
and the most muscles and how they rescue
us from a die-hard-like plot
too easy so much like Kiss reuniting in
1996 for a giant stadium tour to show
all the Young Rockers how it's done
1995's GoldenEye reminded moviegoers
that a spy Adventure can have it all
action music romance comedy one-liners
and a sprawled out worldwide stage to
play on and sometimes outer space but
like all new things the newness and cool
would wear off and by the time Die
Another Day was released in 2002 Bond
felt like he was jumping multiple sharks
in each film some sequences bordered on
parody and the missions themselves felt
so Fantastical that all shreds of
reality vanished faster than a silly car
could disappear in short the franchise
needed another reset but where do you go
from possibly the smoothest most
Debonair Bond of all time the complete
opposite direction step right up Daniel
Craig this 007 was as much a born as he
was a bomb nope a raw nerve whose
fighting style felt like it belonged in
a UFC title fight or a parkour
Championship Daniel Craig's James could
clean up if he had to but he felt much
more at home in a Hawaiian shirt or
boozing deep into the night on a beach
if the Pierce Brosnan film set hearkened
back to the bygone era of epic adventure
the Daniel Craig movies took the modern
action cue from other franchises and
forded ahead of them all Brosnan's Bond
could swing a martini wine and dine in
bed but still be bright out in
bushy-tailed ready to go the next
morning family motto conversely Craig's
007 looks like he hadn't slept at all
the night before and the lack of rest
might have been due to his own demons
rather than a swinging Knight with a
fetching Vixen we all have our secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet so how
do you pick who's the better Bond both
came along at the right time with their
brand of powder if you will but the
Brosnan era set up the Craig run to be
bold and different as much as I wasn't a
fan of the direction the later Pierce
films took he himself was always right
for the role and that's why the flicks
kept making box office Bank the
proverbial baton passing was so much
smoother from Brosnan to Craig because
we were ready for a new take suppose
that's something but in 1995 when
GoldenEye hit it was the most Flawless
melding of the bond that we knew and the
James that could function in a much more
technologically savvy era Daniel Craig
reinvented the role by making it his own
but Pierce Brosnan topped that feat by
reinvigorating the Vintage 007 and
refreshing the concept at the same time
if his bond didn't quite get over with
the fans we're probably discussing this
entire franchise in the way past tense
and for that Pierce Brosnan edges ahead
of Daniel Craig in this round takes the
battle battle and ties the match at two
to two I want to meet your employer and
now it's time for the Wild Card round
relax this final round that will
determine the winner is more chill for a
couple of reasons one I know a lot of
Daniel Craig honks are yelling at me
through their streaming device again
called screaming because I didn't give
their boy the win in round four so let
me be clear here and now the Craig
movies as a whole are better than the
Brosnan ones but Pierce I feel is a
slightly better classic Bond but now we
relax by taking off the tuxes and
donning other costumes that might
function well in movies not set in the
James Bond Universe this round will be
won by Whoever has the most memorable
moments outside of the clandestine walls
of MI6
so Pierce Brosnan is still going to take
an early lead here with the Run by
fruiting I mean come on we still all say
it right hell I think of it every time
I'm in the produce section and
occasionally I'm tempted to toss one
myself Brosnan plays Stu who isn't a bad
guy he's just not dad and so we enjoy
watching him fidget and struggle through
dates with Sally Field and Company we
don't want to kill the guy I'll make
that clear but plunking him in the back
of the head with fruit or over peppering
his dinner that's semi-harm was fun
right
what can I say run the guy's a loser
Pierce is also a Smooth Operator on the
other side of the wall in The Thomas
Crown Affair and multiple sequences show
him off to be a master of thievery and
the Heart well
looks very nice
The Matador reminded us where Margaritas
taste the best and for all you shark
lovers out there like our expert
researcher here on the show Mark
Hoffmeyer there's a lot of good fin
action meanwhile Daniel Craig got
started with some iconic moments well
before he was James born I mean Jason
Bond are you enjoying this layer cake
would kind of be his version of a Thomas
Crown Affair but he can also get super
menacing in Road to Perdition the girl
with a dragon tattoo relies on a slow
boiling stoicism but his intensity can
quickly bring us to a simmer with scenes
like the grenade assassination in Munich
and look I'm not here to bash Pierce
Brosnan singing in Mamma Mia as a matter
of fact I loved it my sentiments exactly
because it proved that this guy's mortal
after all we finally found a slight
weakness after all these years Daniel
Craig has yet to suffer that kind of
career Pitfall but not for his lack of
risk-taking you will find me a
respectful quiet passive Observer his
accent in both Logan lucky and knives
out could have derailed the greatness of
those movies instead it made them stand
out even more the Twisted web scene as
he's piecing together whodunit are the
hilarious and harrowing car chases and
Logan lucky show off a much more
versatile Daniel Craig than might meet
the eye
Brosnan still might be the smoothest guy
on the planet and he'll never not be a
contender for People's sexiest man of
the year an award he did take home in
the early 2000s although to be fair that
was the pre-blake Shelton era but Daniel
Craig has already given us so many
Thrills chills and Spills in a
comparatively young career so my
affection for what I've already seen and
my prognostication that someone
optimistic for what I'm gonna see I'm
awarding this round and thus the match
to Mr Daniel Craig Take a Bow sir
congratulations you know I think the
celebrations in order or just swag some
tequila and trap a scorpion with the
glass you be you I'm a huge fan of both
these fellas inside and outside of an
Aston Martin BMW Z3 or any other
supercharged Auto they might be piloting
both have numerous projects in the works
so maybe we run this match back in a few
years you know when we have a new James
Bond to celebrate and keep in mind this
was all just my opinion now it's your
turn my beloved audience who for some
reason don't embrace the lawnmower man
hit me up on social media with your take
at Mark Ellis live stay tuned right here
at Rotten Tomatoes for all the latest in
the world of TV movies and everything in
between including who may be wearing a
tux in the near future thanks for
watching versus I'm Mark Ellis and
unlike James Bond I'm gonna go to bed
now
alone